[Music]
on this Sunday night worries kovat 19 is
out of control we have to be prepared
for the scenario that this is not
contained why the window till lockdown
the virus may have already closed Bernie
Sanders leading a revolution we are
going to win across the country but can
a self-described socialist unite all
Democrats and Kenney beat Donald Trump
the small gesture with a big impact the
problem is big the problem is real
ending hunger one mailbox pantry at a
time and a very Canadian Cinderella
story how is Sam boney driver scored big
with his NHL debut
global national with Robin Gill
reporting tonight Coleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us we begin
tonight with the story everyone is
talking about a 42 year old Zamboni
driver from Whitby Ontario called in to
NHL action last night David Ayer stepped
up for the Carolina Hurricanes after the
team goalies went down and what he
managed to do in net surpassed
everyone's expectations
Eric Sorenson brings us his amazing
story back on the practice ice for the
Toronto Maple Leafs farm team in an
empty arena Dave airs still pinching
himself a kidney transplant recipient
and the oldest goalie ever to win his
first NHL game at 42 I'm not sure about
the old part but I'll take the win for
sure for the dream to come true first
came a nightmare one Carolina goalie and
then the backup goalies both hurt he
almost never used backup backup goalie
was told to dress quickly how about this
moment oh my goodness
Dave Aires pushed into the spotlight on
Hockey Night in Canada series from would
be played some junior beads
[Applause]
he led in two goals right away and
almost a third as the second period
ended there was a sense of condolence
from the Leafs and his new teammates
when they said to me just have fun with
it don't worry about how many goals go
in just enjoy it and so he did
[ __ ] great he laid in no more
goals stopped every shot in the third
period the first emergency backup to win
an NHL game and was the number one star
teammates thrilled for the win even
happier for him for you
at a home town Rincon Whitby this
morning it gave new meaning to fantasy
hockey what a chance of a lifetime to do
something like that when you hear the
goalie was from your town you get a
little proud and from arenas like this
if there's going to be a Cinderella
there must be a pumpkin look no further
than the Toronto Maple Leafs the
flipside of ayres moment of glory was
the specter of another Leafs season on
the verge of unraveling at least fan
it's disappointing that I can't score on
a 42 year old Zamboni driver that's for
sure and there's some controversy that
the top league in the world turned to a
middle-aged backup to finish an NHL game
they may want to fix that but who would
wish that a story like this could never
happen again
you look around and playing soak it in
as much as you can
you're never gonna remember at all but
it was awesome for his kids and his wife
to everything he's gone through the
person he is the dad he is he's just he
deserves every ounce of this he never
wanted to be in the spotlight but he did
well when he got there
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto and
what did David Ayers get for his NHL
debut aside from international fame and
glory well as per NHL rules Ayers was
paid $500 and gets to keep his game
Jersey if you want to own a number 90
air sure to the Hurricanes will sell you
one the team tweeted Dave will be
getting royalties but we're also working
with him to identify a kidney foundation
that will receive a portion of the
proceeds now to the story now that's
been dominating Canada for weeks those
rail blockades across the country still
going despite stern words from the prime
minister on Friday
Justin Trudeau stated all must calm down
as demonstrations enter their third week
with no end in sight
Global's Morgan camel reports on the
standoff and the pressure to break it
the Sun rises on indigenous
demonstrators on tieing de nagamma hoc
territory it's the 18th day on the front
lines of the rail blockade that has
grounds some businesses and travelers to
a halt from coast to coast that protest
is in support of the wetsuit and
hereditary chiefs who were opposed to a
6.6 million dollar gas pipeline project
in northern BC they want the RCMP to
remove their remote detachments and stop
patrolling in those areas and want
coastal gas link to stop work on their
lands impromptu solidarity protests have
popped up across the country like this
one in Vancouver Sunday afternoon on
Saturday in Saskatoon protesters for and
against pipelines squared off halting
rail traffic for about two hours
wet suet and hereditary Chiefs left a
meeting with indigenous leaders and
Ghana walkway Mohawk territory in Quebec
today but wouldn't address rumors of a
possible alliance in Ontario the
provincial police continued talks with
the Mohawks of the Bay of Quinte just
remains coming to a peaceful resolution
to the situation and ensuring that
everyone and the barricades need to come
down now things appear to be at a
standstill since the prime minister
called for an end to the blockades on
Friday
meantime Via Rail says service along the
Quebec City Montreal and Ottawa corridor
will resume Monday all other via rail
service remains cancelled with the
exception of Sudbury White River and
Churchill the pond about a thousand
employees have been laid off as for sea
and rail service along that line remains
at a standstill as more than 450
employees were handed layoff notices
it would appear these indigenous
supporters aren't going anywhere anytime
soon as they take cover from the wind
sipping coffee near a fire as the OPP
sit parked about a half a kilometer away
morgan campbell global news Tyendinaga
ontario there is some breaking news
tonight on the Cova Denine teen front in
this country first of all air canada has
now confirmed that one of its passengers
who flew from Montreal to Vancouver on
February 14th has tested positive for
the virus the BC Centre for Disease
Control is said to be following up with
passengers from that flight and Ontario
officials say there's a new presumptive
case in Toronto a woman who arrived from
China on Friday is she is in
self-isolation
the province says she wore a mask on her
travels back to Toronto as China and the
world works to contain the deadly spread
of kovat 19 cases continue to rise and
now there's a fear the incubation period
is actually much longer than first
thought the Chinese government confirmed
today that a 70 year old man didn't show
symptoms of the virus until 27 days
later around the globe more than 78,000
people are infected and more than 2,000
have died mostly in mainland China but
the virus is spreading fast numbers are
rising in Japan and there's a red alert
in South Korea after a sixth person died
countries in the Middle East are closing
borders to Iran which recorded 15 new
cases today and three more deaths and in
Europe Austria suspended all trains to
and from Italy as cases in Italy surged
until more about the incubation period
is known it's not yet known if 151
Canadians will now have to spend more
time in quarantine in Cornwall Ontario
but as Heather your ex west reports
Canadian health officials are adjusting
their strategy as hope of containing the
virus begins to fade several communities
in Italy are now under lockdown after
what began as just three cases Friday
soared to more than 150 by Sunday
afternoon in Iran
dozens of sick and at least eight dead
have prompted a number of neighboring
countries including Pakistan to close
their borders and in South Korea where
infections have now soared
600 officials have declared a red alert
leaders in the World Health Organization
have really talked about this closing
window of opportunity to contain the
virus in China but it appears that if
this window truly is closing
it's almost nearly closed or it has
closed on Sunday China's president
acknowledged shortcomings in his
government's response to the outbreak
calling the situation in China still
grim and complex China's efforts to stop
this virus from causing a worldwide
pandemic appear to be failing on Twitter
Canada's chief public health officer
says this country needs to do more now
dr. Teresa Tam wrote it is prudent to
ramp up our planning and preparations in
the case of a more widespread outbreak
the risk to Canadians has not changed
but we must plan for all scenarios
certainly at a health systems level we
can increase the capacity to do
diagnostic testing and really increase
supports to hospitals and healthcare
systems to really accommodate for
perhaps an influx in the number of
patients especially as patients could
arrive in our country now from any
number of countries beyond China
Canada's latest presumed case arrived in
BC from Iran the risk for most Canadians
remains low for now but as the world
reaches a tipping point on this
coronavirus outbreak
health officials know that could change
at any time Heather your exbest Global
News Calgary a massive rescue effort is
underway in Turkey after a 5.7 magnitude
earthquake struck near the border with
Iran killing at least nine people
close to 100 others have been injured
and many more are still believed to be
trapped in the debris thousands of
structures have been reduced to rubble
along remote mountainous regions voter
turnout in Iran's parliamentary election
is believed to be the lowest reported
since 1979 just 42 percent of those
qualified to cast a ballot did so Iran's
supreme leader blamed the low numbers on
negative propaganda surrounding kovat 19
I ran has the highest death toll from
the new coronavirus outside of China
Bernie Sanders big win in the Nevada
caucus means he is now the person to
beat in the Democratic race for the
White House Sanders also won the New
Hampshire primary but that doesn't
necessarily mean smooth sailing is ahead
for the Vermont senator concern is
growing from moderate Democrats they're
worried Sanders can't beat President
Donald Trump in November's general
election Jennifer Johnson reports
Vermont senator Bernie Sanders already
campaigning in delegate-rich Texas one
of 14 states with votes on Super Tuesday
March 3rd Sanders looking ahead of the
campaign's biggest prize after winning
the Nevada caucus surprising critics by
grabbing votes across demographics in
Nevada we have just put together a
multi-generational multiracial coalition
which is gonna not only win in Nevada
it's gonna sweep this country Sanders a
self-described Democratic Socialist is
now the Democrats frontrunner but
moderates fear his policies on health
care and taxes and calls for a political
revolution will turn off swing voters in
the general election against Donald
Trump before we rush to nominate senator
Sanders in our one shot to take on this
president let us take a sober look at
what is at stake
but Sanders remains confident they think
they're gonna win this election by
dividing our people up based on the
color of their skin or where they were
born
we are doing
exactly the opposite we're bringing our
people together ironically Sanders and
Trump do share one elusive quality
they've built a base over the past four
years of supporters who are extremely
loyal and passionate about being part of
a movement senator Sanders has not
stopped campaigning in the twenty-sixth
since the 2016 election and he has
brought in a diverse group of political
strategists and local community leaders
across the board the candidates are now
back on the campaign trail in eight
different states desperate to slow down
the momentum of Bernie Sanders the next
Democratic primary is Saturday in South
Carolina former Vice President Joe Biden
is leading in the polls but Sanders is
nipping at his heels Coleen Jennifer
Johnson in Washington thanks Jennifer
coming up fashion faux pas why the fur
is flying over parks Canada's new parkas
a warm winter coat can be a lifesaver in
this country especially if your job
involves being outdoors in freezing
conditions but should federal employees
tasked with wildlife conservation wear
fur as Jamie Dahl reports new Parks
Canada parkas are raising eyebrows in
Alberta in winter time the Rockies are
breathtaking but they're also bitterly
cold and Parks Canada has to make sure
staff are fully equipped with the proper
gear to withstand the elements well on
the job but the uniform for frigid
weather is causing a heated debate
specifically the coyote fur trimming the
hood I don't think that's acceptable
having fur on your jacket for a Parks
Canada employee especially if it's from
an animal that you don't eat modern
times Thank You faux fur we live in a
time where this is probably unnecessary
Parks Canada says the winter parkas are
issued only to those working in the
coldest conditions like Bath National
Park in a statement to Global News it
says natural fur is more resistant to
moisture and ice buildup and as such
provides greater retention of heat and
protection from the elements peta thinks
otherwise there is no excuse to be
spending government money to buy real
fur we have options that are high tech
that are better for the environment and
that will keep people warm and dry in
the winter so there's just no excuse to
be supporting an industry that the
majority of people find cruel and toxic
and totally unacceptable
it's a polarizing topic a Canada Goose
clothing store recently opened its doors
in Banff and was hit by graffiti critics
said the companies say coyotes and geese
suffer to provide the fur and feathers
used in some of its products
others say faux fur has its own problems
having like some of that's why I do
gradable it's way better than having
some that's artificial and I feel that
that's probably good for a person kind
of do it that way the Canadian fur
industry insists they follow strict
guidelines in this country the fur trade
is extremely well regulated first
produced responsibly and sustainably
wild fur trapping is managed is control
regulated by our provinces and
territories trappers take training
courses before they can have their
trapping permits there's regulated
trapping seasons and then there are
those who are against fur and well don't
even realize they're wearing it what do
you think I think it should be fake fur
I don't think so I mean I presume to
speak for for what I spend on it like
twenty dollars I can't imagine it's
rabbit fur alright then rabbits I'm
sorry a sign of the politics and
pervasiveness of fur in this country
Jamie Dog Global News Banff Alberta just
ahead mailbox pantry's the small gesture
that's making a big difference a
grassroots movement to help feed the
hungry is sprouting up across Canada and
the u.s. similar to as many libraries
that offer free books from front lawns
many pantries offer basic necessities
for people in need and while it may not
be a solution to the problem as Reggie
Cecchini reports the small gesture is
making a big difference for everyone
involved tucked away on a quiet street
corner in Washington DC sits a little
box that looks like one of those little
libraries and while there are no books
inside these boxes tell the story of a
struggle everybody involved in this is
needy
known as many pantries they offer basics
to all members of any community
providing a safe and if needed
anonymous space to receive a helping
hand out some needed because they need
the food and some needed because they
need to be generous it's a grassroots
movement led by individuals churches and
even corporations in the battle to end
hunger and it can trace its roots to the
little free pantry the project started
by a single mother from rural Arkansas
who wanted to expand on the idea of
bringing people together it just became
obvious to me that there was something
going on that little free library space
that was resonating with all kinds of
people around that same time some
statistics came out about hunger and our
I think once I put it all together I
knew what I was gonna do with it that
was in 2016 today there are nearly 1,000
boxes across the US and Canada and now
spreading across the world the number is
really these many pantries act like a
sustainable community allowing anyone to
give or take without judgment and as
needed but the boxes despite their
importance are only a short-term
solution the problem is big the problem
is real food insecurities impact more
than 40 million Americans while in
Canada almost 2 in 10 people feel the
effects of hunger food banks provide
life-saving resources for users but
there are limitations depending on
mobility and location we are really
trying to find ways where we can have a
bank system that is going to be more
available more accessible stigma can
also prevent someone from seeking help
so these 24-hour neighborhood pantries
can break that that's a great thing
about it no identity is required you
don't you know there's no application
there's also no pressure the idea allows
anyone to take the first step take what
you need you have what you can enhancing
the well-being of a community with a
sense of compassion and understanding
regi Guinea Global News Washington next
75 years later a survivor recounts one
of the bloodiest battles in modern
history
seventy-five years ago today
US Marines raced the American flag over
evil Jima it's an iconic wartime image
but the battle didn't end when the Stars
and Stripes were planted on the small
Pacific island fighting raged on as the
US tried to stop Japan from expanding
its control through Southeast Asia and
the Central Pacific as crystal
commencing reports 75 years later
efforts are now underway to remember
those on the front lines
[Music]
it was during the last year of the
second world war that America embarked
on this amphibious assault in the
Pacific Theater the Marines were sent to
take a tiny island of strategic
importance called Iwo Jima it was meant
to stop Japan's expansion efforts in the
region what they experienced is
something time has not erased
I am Major William C white
United States Marine Corps all 5 5 7 2 3
were born on 31 July 1915 and right now
I am 104 years of age his battle years
are behind him major bill white lives in
an assisted facility in California he's
believed to be the oldest survivor of
Iwo Jima if he recalls with clarity the
day he almost died
he created exploded shoving back against
the wall like I had no idea what was
what was going on I was probably dead
but I managed to get up and find my way
back through the Marines the Americans
didn't know the Japanese had roughly 17
kilometers of tunnels the attacks nearly
impossible to predict and the fighting
relentless 7,000 Marines were killed the
Japanese suffered nearly three times
that the hard-fought battle that was
waged for 36 days would spur Admiral
Chester Nimitz to remark that uncommon
valor was a common virtue a virtue still
exhibited by major white his pride is
evident I occasionally have thoughts
about them or visions what had happened
or what might have happened
that's just memories the bombing and
shelling in that conflict was so intense
it altered the very landscape around it
permanently changing the shape of Mount
Suribachi and that iconic photo of
troops raising the flag serves as a
reminder of the conflict it's
immeasurable toll and the hope that
Springs from
it crystal dancing global news at London
that is global national for this Sunday
I'm Colleen Christie tonight's your
Canada is three-mile lake in Ontario
thanks for watching have a good night
[Music]
you